zwei Dinge die sagen wir müssen
präzisieren was eigentlich Staatsraison
wirklich heißt msen genauer definieren
genau können Sie gleich ausführen was
sie damit meinen das zweite ist sie
sagen wenn wir sozusagen sofort
Antisemitismus rufen jetzt frei
interpretiert dann führt das dazu dass
wir die Grenzen des Sagbaren immer
weiter sousagen einengen oder oder
kleiner machen das bedeutet dass wir
dann legitime Kritik an israelischer
Politik z.B siedungspolitik
die führen wir dann nicht mehr und das
ist nicht gut für den öffentlichen
Diskurs habe ich Sie richtig verstanden
das ist richtig ich glaube zu nächst mal
müssen wir uns darüber im Klaren sein
was wir erreichen wollen wir wollen
erreichen dass alle Menschen in
Deutschland jüdisches Leben in
Deutschland schützen dass Jüdinnen und
Juden in Deutschland sich sicher fühlen
müssen das ist das oberste Ziel und das
zweite große Ziel ist dass alle Menschen
anerknen anerkennen dass Israel ein
Existenzrecht hat dass wir diesen Staat
als jüdischen Staat brauchen im Nahen
Osten wie kommen wir dahin meine meine
Kritik ist wie kommen wir dahin wir
kommen da nicht hin indem wir den Leuten
bei der Einbürgerung ein Stück Papier
vorlegen und sagen bitte unterschreiben
ich bin solidarisch mit Israel das ist
der falsche Weg sondern was wir brauchen
ist eben ein erweitertest bzw ein
präzisere Formulierung von staatsreson
staatsreson definiert als die Sicherheit
des Staates Israels klingt nach einer
Formel wird zum Teil zur staatlichen
Doktrin hat also sehr viel mit einem
erstarten Diskurs zu tun und wird dann
häufig auch ausgelegt als eine
Solidarität mit der aktuellen reg z.B in
der Weise wie auch dieser Krieg geführt
wird weil ja Außenministerin berbock
sich nach wie vor ja auch nicht für
einen Waffenstillstand einsetzt sondern
Waffenruhen fordert das kann man machen
aber dann muss man gleichzeitig schon
auch Einwirken auf die israelische
Kriegsführung in Gaza z.B das heißt
indem wir die staatsresor definieren
über nur den Staat Israel und weniger
die Menschen das wäre mein Appell dass
wir uns fragen müssen was müssen wir tun
für die Sicherheit der Menschen in
Israel und da kann es ja sehr wohl sein
dass die Regierung die aktuelle
Regierung womöglich nicht im Sinne der
Sicherheit
die is
gzt seh viele Menschen Isel kriieren ja
die Regierung n eben nicht die Priorität
richtig gesetzt hat für die Sicherheit
sondern sehr wohl andere ein genau bei
diesem Thema bleiben ich merke bei
schinberg brodels bei Eva qu Ladies
first sie dürfen zuerst und dann
arbeiten wir das einmal weil ein heißes
Eisen über das wir jetzt reden Frau
Quadbeck wie wie schauen sie da drauf
also ich glaube dass man unbedingt einen
differenzierten Blick braucht ich möchte
aber an an einer Stelle wiedersprechen
nämlich dann wenn wir sehen dass ich
wirklich Antisemitismus offen auf
unseren Straßen abspielt dann würde ich
jetzt nicht die in Schutz nehmen wollen
die hinter diesen Fahnen herlaufen
sondern dann würde ich sagen da muss der
Staat wirklich hart gegen vorgehen und
das hat Deutschland ja ausnammsweise
dann in dem Fall auch getan erschrocken
durch den 7 Oktober und auch
aufgeschreckt dadurch welche Art von
Antisemitismus V allen Dingen auf
berlinerstraßen teilweise im Ruhrgebiet
sich zeigt und hat reagiert sagen sie im
reagieren und da finde ich ist es auch
in wie genau haben wir hart reagiert ja
dass Leute die dann eben entsprechende
Parolen ausgegeben haben wirklich
festgenommen worden sind und den dann
wurde verboten die Hamas hat ein
Betätigungsverbot so also gut bei Hamas
Betätigungsverbot und da hätte ich schon
fast gedacht hups dass wir das noch
nicht haben aber und das ist eben das
das Betätigungsverbot übrigens auch
schon läer Problems wir haben eben
überzer machen es dann trotzdem das will
ich nur sagen wir haben eben über
Zuwanderung gesprochen und wir haben die
Zuwanderung der vergangenen Jahrzehnte
bisher noch gar nicht bewältigt in dem
Sinne dass die Menschen also dass
wirklich ähm ausreichend Menschen
integriert sind dass das zu einem
gesellschaftlichen Konsens und zu dem
was sie da gerade schildern zu soem
gesellschaftlichen Konsens führen kann
dass tatsächlich Israel anerkennt wird
in seinem Existenzrecht und deshalb ist
natürlich auch der Begriff der
Staatsraison so schwierig weil es ist
erst weder in der Verfassung noch als er
steht in irgendeinem Gesetz es ist ein
politischer Begriff und er bedeutet
jetzt erst einmal dass ähm
Israel auch wenn es viel Kritik an
Israel zu üben gibt aber Israel die
Solidarität gehört und dass wenn wir
wissen dass Juden Jüden auf unseren
Straßen nicht sicher sind dass der
deutsche Staat da Schutz ausübt und das
ist ja schon so dass
die Juden sich in der Minderheit sehen
und
mehr Juden bedroht sind als das radikale
Muslime bedroh wären und da müssen wir
schon aufpassen dass wir die Debatte
nicht von den Füßen auf den Kopf stellen
okay Herr Steinberg sie und dann Herr
trtin erst noch mal zur zur Hamas das
ist richtig das ist eine nationale
Organisation aber eine mannung zur
Vorsicht die PFLP die Volksfront für die
Befreiung Palästinas das war immer eine
nationale Organisation die hat nur die
Israelis bekämpft bis sie sich
entschieden hat international zu agieren
Entführung eines Flugzeugs der Lal das
ist der Beginn des Forschungsgebiet
Gebiets internationaler Terrorismus
deswegen die mannung zur Vorsicht die
Hisbollah ist ohnehin eine
internationale Organisation die hat auch
schon Anschläge auf israelische
Touristen in Bulgarien verübt vor jetzt
z zehneinhalb Jahren das stimmt ja das
darf das dar das darf man nicht
vergessen und es geht darum sich darüber
Gedanken zu machen frühzeitig Gedanken
zu machen wann denn solche
internationalisierungsprozesse beginnen
können beim Thema Antisemitismus bin ich
staatsreson waren wir gerade ja da
staatsreson Antisemitismus da bin ich in
äh in einigen Aspekten ganz breit bei
Frau Hellberg mich hat es tatsächlich
erstaunt wie wenig Meinungsfreiheit
zugelassen wurde in Deutschland im
Vergleich zu anderen Staaten ich
verfolge die Politik natürlich in den
USA sehr genau da wurde in der Politik
in der Öffentlichkeit an den
Universitäten viel freier diskutiert und
ich glaube auch dass der deutsche Staat
an einigen Punkten Fehler gemacht hat es
gab eine ganz deutliche Diskrepanz was
äh was die Genehmigungen für
Demonstrationen anging zwischen
Nordrhein-Westfalen und in Berlin da
wurde in den ersten Tagen kaum etwas
kaum etwas genehmigt insofern bin ich
schon der Meinung dass da auch der
deutsche Staat etwas mehr hätte zulassen
können man kann solche Demonstrationen
ja mit Auflagen versehen die Polizei
kann angreifen möglicherweise war da der
Grund auch Kapazitätsproblem in in
Berlin trotzdem die Diskrepanz der
Unterschied zwischen deutsch und den USA
wo Meinungsfreiheit anders definiert
wird fre spe geht sehr viel weiter dort
der war der der war aus meiner Sicht
sehr sehr sehr deutlich ich glaube
allerdings nicht
dass da irgendetwas kaputt irgendetwas
kaputt gemacht wurde und vor allem
glaube ich nicht an eine Verbindung
zwischen Extremismus und terroristischer
Radikalisierung und dem Verbot von
Demonstrationen der einäung von von von
Meinungsfreiheit das ist es ist ganz
einfach so dass man es in der Regel mit
jungen Leuten zu tun hat die ohnehin in
in diese in die in diese Richtung gehen
aber das Phänomen dass das in
Deutschland anders gehandhabt wurde und
auch im Ausland oft oft sehr kritisch
gesehen wurde das ist schon aber die
Szenen die sich teilweise an
amerikanischen Unis abgespielt haben die
sind natürlich über die Meinungsfreiheit
weit hinausgegangen ne ja genau aber
auch ich habe ich habe das sind
sicherlich die Auswüchse des Ganzen aber
es gab eine eine Abgeordnete rashida
kleib arabische Abstammung die hat ganz
offen gesagt wir wollen palästiner
befreien vom Fluss Jordan bis ans
Mittelmeer die ist enorm in die Kritik
geraten ja die ist auch offiziell gerügt
worden im Kongress aber trotzdem diese
Dinge diese Dinge wurden diskutiert die
wurden hier nicht diskutiert die wurden
hier letztenb ist auch wenn man wenn man
jemanden wie weiß nicht Tony blinkon den
Außenminister z.B sehr früh schon den
amerikanischen gehört hat es warä schon
sehr interessant wie das kontrastiert
auch mit mit der deutschen Position mit
do also der Außenministerin ihrer Partei
mit analena berbock blinken sagte sehr
deutlich ganz früh israel hat natürlich
das Recht sich zu verteidigen erster
Punkt aber zweiter Punkt wie ihr das
macht darüber müssen wir bitte reden so
ist es na ja das sagen wir nicht doch
sagen wir das so laut und deutlich steht
sogar in dem einstimmigen
Bundestagsbeschluss drinne den der
Bundestag gefasst hat ich rede jetzt von
der von der Außenministerin redet unsere
Außenministerin so redet die
Außenministerin so redet sie in Israel
so redet sie in in den arabischen
Staaten ich schau gerade zu Frau
Hellberg ich ja sie redet im
Kleingedruckten redet sie so das ist
richtig aber das was sie vor sich
herträgt aus Angst falsch verstanden zu
werden aus Angst kritisiert zu werden
für zu viel Kritiker an Israel ist ich
zitiere noch mal auch Kanzler Scholz der
gesagt hat natürlich ist Israel weil es
eine Demokratie ist eine lebendige
Demokratie ist natür nlich wird sich
Israel aners Völkerrecht halten das
steht gar
nicht sagen aber das ist ja auch noch
mal nein aber wie ist die Wahrnehmung
dessen wie nehmen Menschen das wahr die
jetzt Verwandte in Gaza haben wenn sich
der Kanzler nach so vielen Wochen dieses
Krieges in Gaza über den man diskutieren
kann dass er notwendig ist natürlich wie
er geführt wird ob das der Sicherheit
Israels dient das kann man alles
diskutieren aber sich dann hinzustellen
und einfach sich nur zu verstecken
hinter der Tatsache dass Israel
natürlich eine Demokratie ist aber
Demokratien halten sich nicht unbedingt
an Völkerrecht sch sich die USA an im
Irak igung das ist ja keine Garantie
dass ein Staat völkerrechtskonform
agiert nur weil es eine Demokratie ist
deswegen wird das von vielen
wahrgenommen als ziemlich zynisch dann
noch zu sagen ja natürlich ist das alles
noch im Rahmen der Verhältnismäßigkeit
jetzt sind sie gesprungen sie haben auf
die Außenministerin verwiesen und haben
sich dann am Kanzler abgearbeitet ich
verweise nur darauf die Rede der
Außenministerin in Kairo auf der
Konferenz wo wir einer der wenigen
europäischen Staaten war wo sie genau
das gesagt hat nicht im kleinedrucken
sondern sehr deutlich ich verweise
darauf was sozusagen gegenstand der
Gespräche gewesen ist zwischen ihr
Netanyahu Benny ganz bei der Reise die
sie drei Tage vor mir an der Stelle
gemacht hat das habe ich denn ja von der
anderen Seite auch wieder gespiegelt
gekriegt Deutschland hat die ganze Zeit
ausgehend und das ist der Unterschied zu
einer Situation wie in Großbritannien
oder in den USA in diesen beiden Ländern
sind an einem Wochenende 300.000
Menschen auf die Straße gegangen um
gegen den Krieg in G
zu demonstrieren wir haben hier eine
andere Haltung dazu gehabt und das hat
etwas mit unserer Geschichte zu tun mit
der Verantwortung vor unserer Geschichte
aber auf der Basis dieser Verantwortung
die sagt unsere historische
Verpflichtung ist es sicherzustellen
dass das Existenzrecht Israels als
Heimstadt der judinen und Juden der Welt
als demokratisches Israel dass das nicht
in Frage gestellt wird haben wir sehr
deutlich gesagt wir können nicht
akzeptieren was in der Westbank passiert
hat uns viel Kritik auch hier von der
Botschaft eingebracht sehr klar gesagt
die Form der Kriegsführung muss dem
Völkerrecht entsprechen wir brauchen
mehr Zugänge für humanitäre Hilfe gegen
massives Lobbying und ich kann ihn paar
Fraktionen nennen die da Diel hat die
Außenministerin darauf bestanden dass
zwei Dinge in der bundestagsresolution
drinne steht nämlich erstens dass wir
die humanitäre Hilfe ausweiten und nicht
blockieren das ist gefordert worden und
zum
zweiten das endgültige Sicherheit oder
eine nachhaltige Sicherheit so heißt es
da glaube ich eine nachhaltige
Sicherheit für den Staat Israels nur mit
einer politischen Lösung gibt die
verhandelt wird zwischen Palästinensern
und Israelis also ich finde das kann man
nicht alles unter Kleingedruckten W wer
lobbiiert da Herr TR da gibt es immer
welche die an dieser Stelle so
Organisation wie NAFO und ähnlichen und
das ist ja auch legitim ich habe nichts
gegen gen Lobbyismus ich sag nur wenn
Sie diese Haltung die wir in der in den
Koalitionsfraktionen aber auch mit der
Christlich Demokratischen Union zu
führen hatten dann waren das keine
leichten auseinandersetzen die am Ende
zu diesem einstimmigen Beschluss über
den ich sehr froh bin deswegen ist das
für mich jetzt kein Anlass irgendjemand
zu blamen am Ende geführt hat aber es
war die behaligkeit der grünen Fraktion
der Grünen Außenministerin die gesagt
hat Zweistaatenlösung und Ausweitung der
humanitären Hilfe mm das stimmt das
stimmt sachlich ja die Außenministerin
hat immer wieder immer wieder
Bemerkungen in diese in in diese
Richtung gemacht auch zur siedlergewalt
zuletzt im im im Westjordanland ich
glaube allerdings dass das Problem ist
dass das was ankommt wenn man nun nicht
wirklich in in die deutsche und auch in
die internationale Presse sich
hineinwühlt das was ankommt ist vor
allem die Position der Deutschen gegen
gegenüber Israel das ist tatsächlich das
was auch in der arabischen Welt
wahrgenommen wird und was
uns das würde das würde soweit wber sagt
wür sie
dasber sagt nein ich ich sage das nicht
weil ganz einfach die Israelis sind ein
Freund und Verbündeter es macht durchaus
Sinn zunächst einmal zu sagen wir stehen
in bei in diesem Krieg gegen die Hamas
an eurer Seite und das bringt uns auch
einen gewissen Vertrauensvorschuss in
Israel wenn dann wenn es dann nämlich
demnächst um politische Fragen geht um
die zwei staatenlösung um vielleicht
einen Siedlungsstopp um ein Ende der
siedlergewalt dann wird Deutschland
gehört werden und nicht Spanien
allerdings muss man sagen äh die
Position die hat Deutschland in ganz
ganz vielen Ländern in die Kritik
gebracht alleine alleine schon in
Spanien ich hatte ganz viele
spanischen Journalisten die mich gefragt
haben ja bitte bitte erklär das doch mal
weil hier ist immer vom Schuldkomplex
die rede ja und das ist ja ja das ist
natürlich Quatsch aber das war in in in
Spanien ein ganz großes Thema warum die
deutschen jetzt so uneingesränt
proisraelisch sind das zeigt eben dass
nichts anderes angekommen ist und ich
glaube dass da das
Außenministerium die Frau berbock und
auch andere Politiker noch etwas na
nachlegen könnten damit auch öffentlich
klar wird dass ihre Position eigentlich
eine ganz vernünftige ist die viel
ausgewogener ist als das nach Auen hin
an der Stelle würde ich gerne auf die
unresolution verweisen wo sich
Deutschland enthalten hat dafür hat es
viel Kritik gegeben auch von Israel
und doch nein es hat KR ich wierspreche
Ihnen entschieden ich ich wollte ich
wollte jetzt gerade lassen Sie mich ein
Moment Ausreden Herr ich wollte gerade
verteidigen dass die Bundesregierung
diese
UN-Resolution sich dort enthalten hat
das war aus meiner Sicht die richtige
Entscheidung Deutschland hätte keine
Resolution
unterschreiben können in der die Hamas
nicht als Aggressor genannt ist und in
der nicht auch erwähnt worden wäre dass
eben Geiseln genommen worden sind
Deutschland aber Deutschland hat sich
dann entschieden sich zu enthalten weil
in dieser Resolution eben auch drin
steht dass man einen sofortigen
Waffenstillstand im gazerastreifen
gefordert hat das war Mitte Oktober und
von Israel hat es zu dieser also hat es
zu dieser Enthaltung Kritik gegeben und
ich würde aber sagen die Bundesregierung
hat sich an der Stelle richtig verhalten
weil sie nämlich genau da diese Position
eingenommen hat dass sie auch noch eine
Chance hat als Mittlerin im Nahen Osten
aufzutreten der der Anspruch wird mich
jetzt wirklich sehr interessieren so
emotional habe ich sie schon lange nicht
mehr erlebt her
trtin ist ein Unterschied die Israelis
haben diese Resolution missbilligt und
halten die für falsch aber die
Behauptung äh dass das äh Verhalten
Deutschlands in diesem Prozess in Israel
scharf kritisiert würde hätten wir ja
mitbekommen müssen ich war beim
Außenministerium ich war ja ja der
Botschafter ist eine ganz eigene ganz
eigene Veranstaltung ich war war beim
Außenministerium ich war beim Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat ich war bei der
wichtigsten Partei dieser Koalition liut
ich war bei der größten
laizistischen oppositionspar Partei und
alle haben gesagt ihr habt das richtig
gemacht ihr seid unsere verlässlichen
Freunde neben den Amerikanern und das
hatte einen Grund weil nämlich die
Resolution so wie die Jordanier sie in
die Generalversammlung eingebracht haben
eine locker eine Mehrheit bekommen hätte
was ist anders geworden durch die
Intervention von Kanada Großbritannien
und Deutschland ist bin anders geworden
erstens dass diese Attacke vom 7 oktober
als Terrorismus qualifiziert wurde und
zum zweiten dass die Freilassung aller
Zivilisten gef fordert worden sind das
ist der Grund warum Deutschland gesagt
hat auf dieser Basis können wir uns
enthalten und das waren die konkreten
Verbesserungen die erreicht worden sind
und das ist in Israel durchaus zur
Kenntnis genommen worden das muss Israel
sich nicht zu eigen machen aber ich
finde den Diskurs der in Deutschland
stattgefunden hat den habe ich nun
gerade deswegen habe ich so klar
widersprochen beim Besuch in Israel in
keiner Weise von keiner Seite Gehör wir
deuts die Debatte
anders nur das muss man no mal genauso
wie in USA sie anders läuft nur zur
Erinnerung auch ihr eigener Vizekanzler
Wirtschaftsminister Robert hab hat hier
im Gespräch mit uns gesagt diese
Resolution ist schlecht kein guter Text
kann man auch gerne noch mal nach hören
wie er das begründet war sehr
interessant würd aber gerne weil wir
nicht mehr so viel Zeit haben es ist
jetzt schon mehrfach gefallen
das Stichwort West jordanland
Westbank und daran das ist mein Gefühl
auch wenn man wir haben immer wieder
versucht auch die palästinensische
Stimme hier in dieser Sendung zu hören
und ich kann an dem Punkt nur bestätigen
was sie sagen auch was sie sagen Herr
Steinberg es war nicht einfach diese
Stimme hier in die Sendung überhaupt zu
kriegen weil die Leute Angst haben genau
vor diesem Diskurs und
sagen wir fühlen uns dabei nicht wohl
und es gibt so viel Ärger das machen wir
lieber nicht und was immer wieder kommt
als Stichwort ist das was die Zustände
im Westjordanland sind die Kritik an
israelischer
Siedlungspolitik können Sie einmal
beschre daiert wie viele Menschen sind
seit dem 7 Oktober allein im
Westjordanland gestorben durch die Hand
militanter israelischer Siedler
giat555 nicht
durch5 und ungefähr 9 oder 10 durch
Siedler faktisch herrscht im westjordan
streheit sind durch Soldaten
erschossen und in der Regel in den a
Gebieten das sind die Gebiete wo
eigentlich die tinensische Verwaltung
die Sicherheit sicherstellen aufil mus
einmalen ab B und CAU aber ich will ja
mal was weitergehen diese Politik wird
ja auch in Israel massiv kritis sind in
Israel ich habe in Israel Oppositionelle
getroffen die der Regierung Netanyahu
vorwerfen dass
sie diesen Terroranschlag vom 7 Oktober
ermöglicht hätten die haben mir
vorgetragen ich konnte die Zahlen nicht
überprüfen aber deswegen zitiere ich sie
nur dass zu demem Zeitpunkt zwei
Brigaden im Süden stationiert gewesen
sein aber 32 Brigaden der israelischen
Armee im Westjordanland zur Absicherung
der Siedlung und der
Politik der annextion die dort unter
Netanyahu wirklich eskaliert ist
durchgeführt und da machen diejenigen
die Regierung Netanyahu für
verantwortlich an völlig falsche
militärische Prioritätensetzung genau
der Vorwurf ich meinte mit der
Sicherheit dass diese Regierung
verantwortlich dafür gemacht hat falsche
Prioritäten gesetzt zu haben und eben
nicht die Sicherheit der Menschen der
vor war sozusagen ihr schützt nicht
junge Leute
die harmlose sisrael feiern sonder die
Siedler militanten Siedler sind euch
wichtiger weil ein Teil davon oder ein
wichtiger Teil davon eure Wählerschaft
ist das war der V weil sie in der
Regierung
sitzen
der vorwf genau bin jetzt an einem
kleinen persönlichen Beispiel erläutern
ja ich habe vor 6 Jahren haben wir 10
Jahren ist fast her haben wir ein
Projekt besichtigt das wird von der für
internationale Zusammenarbeit betreut
das war der Versuch Beduinen die dort
lebten mit Strom auszustatten
Photovoltaik die lebten damals noch in
Zelten damals gab es in der
Nachbarschaft eine Siedlung die war da
die war nach israelischem Gesetz nach
israelischem Gesetz nicht nach
Besatzungsrecht nach dem israelischen
Gesetze damals
illegalau bin jetzt 10 Jahre später
wieder hingekommen die Situation für die
Familie hatte sich etwas gebessert sie
leben nicht mehr in Zelten sondern jetzt
im
Container aber die Siedlung ist nun
erstens ans öffentliche Wassernetz und
an die abwassersachen angeschlossen und
zweitens um die Siedlung herum ist ein 3
km breite Zone gezogen worden
abgesichert durch die israelische Armee
die in die kein Palästinenser rein
durfte man wir reden jetzt nicht über
Gebiete wo die willkürlich reingehen
sondern da stehen zum Teil die
Olivenbäume und und Gartenanlagen werden
die Schafe und Ziegen gehalten und das
ist dern Land da dürfen die nicht mehr
hin damit war die israelische Armee
beschäftigt und jetzt kommt in der
jetzigen Situation hinzu dass die
Siedler dazu übergegangen sind neben den
regulären Checkpoints noch wilde
Checkpoints zu machen das hat wiederum
dazu geführt dass wir bei dem Versuch
Menschen aus dem Kriegsgebiet als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu evakuieren
wir haben ja auch versucht aus dem
Westjordanland dort lebende Deutsche
rauszubringen das nicht mehr tun konnten
weil wir das über Amann in Jordanien
gemacht haben weil kein Taxifahrer mehr
gefahren ist wegen dieser illegalen
Checkpoint das heißt wir haben dort
wirklich eine Situation kompletter
Illegalität und Straflosigkeit unter der
die PalästinenserInnen und Palästinenser
in den Gebieten die ihnen sogar zur
Selbstverwaltung zugewiesen sind heute
leben müssen a Gebieten ne da kommen wir
zu den Dingen die nicht sagbar sind und
das will ich vielleicht einmal noch mal
ein bisschen erklären was ich damit
meine denn wir sind uns alle einig dass
diese Siedlung illegal sind dass es
nicht geht wir haben immer wieder
Kommentare auch gehört natürlich der
Europäischen Union man hat es verurteilt
das waren alles leere Worte aus sichicht
der Palästinenserin und Palästinenser im
Westjordanland die eben seit 30 Jahren
sehen dass Verhandlungen und Kompromisse
mit der israelischen Seite nur zu mehr
Siedlung geführt haben das hat ja auch
die Palästinensische Autonomiebehörde
unter Mahmud Abbas die ganze
Glaubwürdigkeit gekostet weil sie
eigentlich ein füllungsgehilfe ist
dieser Sicherheitsinteressen weil sie ja
kooperieren mit Israel und keinen
einzigen palästinensischen Gefangenen
freibekommen haben durch diese
Kooperation im Gegensatz zu Hamas die
leider jetzt Geiseln genommen hat und
palästinensische Gefangene frei beekommt
durch dieses schreckliche Verbrechen was
ist also das Problem wir kritisieren
Siedlungen das ist richtig und die
Palästinensische Autonomiebehörde und
Menschenrechtsorganisation haben sich
sehr darum bemüht diesen Zustand im
Westjordanland juristisch aufarbeiten zu
lassen und es ist zu einem gewissen Teil
gelungen denn dieser Zustand wird
beschrieben als eine
institutionalisierte und strukturelle
Benachteiligung einer
Bevölkerungsgruppen nämlich der
Palästinenser durch eine andere und zwar
auf Dauer angelegt und das ist das
entscheidende und das ist die Definition
von Apartheit das ist die Definition von
einem apartheitystem W gerade sagen der
Unterschied ist genau das ist das was
ich meine
mit ich nicht teile aber da kommt das
Wort in die de nicht Israel ist als
Ganzes ein apartheitsstaat Nein aber die
Realität imest jordanland das System das
dort institutionell und
strukturell funktioniert ist ein apat
System das ist die Definition 1998
römischer Statut wir haben den
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
eingerichtet da wird es genau definiert
als ein Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit die Tatsache dass sich
die Palästinenser darum bemüht haben das
international völkerrechtlich mal so zu
benennen und dagegen vorzugehen wurde
torpediert im Westen von sehr vielen
verschiedenen Regierung von der
britischen Regierung wir haben gesagt
das kann man so nicht sagen das ist
verboten das das ist das was ich meine
da müssen wir uns ehrlich machen und
genau hinschauen und eben nicht pauschal
ganz Israel zum apartheitstaat zu
erklären wie das auch eine antikoloniale
linke Bewegung weltweit macht die Israel
nur sehen als ein koloniales Projekt das
ist auch überhaupt nicht so wie wir es
sehen wie gesagt israel muss in seiner
Existenz eren aber die Realität im
westjördernland das ist Apartheit und
auch das muss man benennen Herr
Steinberg wie würden sie das nennen
erster Punkt und zweiter Punkt weil sie
die Situation dort auch sehr gut kennen
ich habe das selber auch mit eigenen
Augen mehrfach
gesehen man muss das mal beschreiben was
das bedeutet diese diese Siedlungen
also kommen sozusagen willkürlich
letzten Endes so nehmen es die Leute
dort auch wahr Menschen vorbei Siedler
oder auch die Armee man muss auch gar
nicht groß begründen warum man eine
hertia durchführt oder so man kann auch
einfach sagen da vermut ist ist
strukturell man muss auch vorbeikommen
und dann werden Menschen die eben noch
in diesem Haus gewohnt haben die sind
dann plötzlich weg und haben dieses Haus
nicht mehr oder wie muss ich mir das
vorstellen und dann entstehen überall so
kleine Inseln in diesem Gebiet die dann
quasi geschützt sind und Straßen führen
drum herum ja man muss allerdings glaube
ich z ja man ein Flickenteppich ist
richtig aber man muss glaube ich zwei
Dinge zunächst einmal unter
unterscheiden nämlich die Präsenz von
Militär und die Präsenz von Siedlern wir
haben nun zunächst einmal die Präsenz
von Militär an Orten wo israelisches
Militär schon seit langer Zeit
eigentlich nicht mehr vorgesehen ist wo
aber die Palästinenserbehörde in ramalla
die Kontrolle verloren hat und da sehen
wir jetzt seit etwa anderthalb Jahren
eine enorme Verschlechterung der
Sicherheitslage vor allem im nördlichen
Teil des
Westjordanlands rund um die Städte Genin
plus Flüchtlingslager und wo liegt das
ungefähr wenn wir hier diese Karte sehen
da ungefähr wo dieser weiße Pfeil
Westjordanland endet da ist ziemlich
genau Genin und da sehen wir seit etwa
anderthalb Jahren eine enorme
Verschlechterung der Sicherheitslage die
Palästinenser Regierung versucht gar
nicht mal mehr dort die Kontrolle zu
behalten das überlässt sie den Israelis
das ist diese dieses a Gebiet und das
liegt an zwei Dingen zunächst einmal
haben wir da eine ganz neue Generation
von jungen Kämpfern die sich bewaffnen
die nicht zur Hamas gehören die nicht
zur vertach gehören die auf eigene
Rechnung die natürlich sich kennen aber
die für sich selbst Kämpen die sich
radikalisiert haben genau und die größte
Gruppe dort die nennt sich ganz schön
die löwenhöhle frei übersetzt und
diese diese jungen Männer die
unterscheidet von den ja von den von den
militanten der letzten Jahre im
Westjordanland dass sie Waffen haben
m und zwar gibt es eine richtige richtig
gehehende Pipeline die entspringt in
Syrien über Jordanien da gibt es jetzt
seit 2 D Jahren etwa einen neuen
Waffenschmuggel der dazu geführt hat
dass diese Gruppierungen auch bewaffnet
sind und damit für die Israelis viel
gefährlicher was dazu füht woher kommen
diese Waffen ganz kurz wer liefert aus
Syrien die Israelis machen in der Regel
Iran dafür verantwortlich es spricht
einiges dafür dass die Iraner zumindest
daran beteiligt sind allerdings ist es
auch ein kriminelles Unterfangen
was aus der israelischen Armee sind
gerade in deren Händen was man das auch
was man feststellen kann ist die Zahl
der Kämpfer wächst die Zahl der Waffen
wächst und das führt dazu dass die
Israelis immer härter durch äh
durchgreifen und deswegen auch die hohe
Zahl der Toten das ist das eine Phänomen
und das zweite Phänomen ist dass wir es
mit einer Siedlerbewegung zu tun haben
genauso wie sie das beschreiben das sind
nicht die etablierten Siedlungen die
dort gut geschützt und seit längerer
Zeit an ganz bestimmten Orten liegen das
sind vor allem die kleineren Siedlungen
die teilweise auch illegal nach
israelischem Recht gegen den Willen der
israelischen regier gegründet worden die
sich ausbreiten in denen viele Militante
Siedler sitzen und die nun seit ungefähr
einem Jahr seit diese Regierung an der
Macht ist die Schutz haben durch die
siedlervertreter in der Regierung immer
offensiver Auftreten und die
mitittlerweile die entweder einmal so
die die örtlichen Olivenbauern
drangalieren teilweise mit Todesfolge
genau also umbringen ne sie haben neun
aus neun Dörfern seit dem 7 Oktober die
Bewohner vertrieben das und das ist
jetzt das was was dazu kommt da werden
Dörfer aber auch ganze kleinere Städte
die werden von denen angegriffen und
zwar unter dem Schutz des israelischen
Militärs mit ganz fürchterlichen Folgen
für die lokale Bevölkerung teils mit
Todesfolge ich würde einmal verstehen
nur weil aus dieser deutschen
Perspektive und auch europäischen
kapiert man das nicht woher kommen diese
Leute wer s wer ist das komm plötzlich
komm in USA das sind jüdische Siedler
die sind das sind Teile der
Siedlerbewegung nur sind junge Leute die
sich bewaffnen die ganz klar das Ziel
haben das Westjordanland insgesamt zu
übernehmen und möglichst viele
Palästinenser aus ihren ihren
Wohngebieten zu vertreiben und die
israelische Regierung geht nicht
entschlossen gegen diese
militanteniedler vor und das führt dazu
dass da regelmäßig dann ein Mob durch
die Straßen von Hara Beispiel ielweise
das ist ein Hotspot dieser
Auseinandersetzung ja ganz wichtige
Stadt für die für die Identität des
Kampfes dort zieht und es sind sogar da
werden dann Menschen angegriffen sie
werden verprügelt da werden auch Autos
oder auch Geschäfte an angezündet und ab
und zu kommt sogar mal ein ein Mensch zu
Tode und das ist einer der Gründe dafür
warum die Stimmung nicht nur im
Westjordanland sondern insgesamt in der
palästinensischen Community in der
Region und weltweit natürlich am Kochen
ist gut und das kommt ja dazu noch zu
dieser ganz grundsätzlichen
Diskriminierung die seit Jahrzehnten
andauert das ist jetzt eine Entwicklung
der letzten anderthalb Jahre was sie
geschildert haben noch in dieser vhemenz
aber wir haben ja gesehen dass alle
Regierungen eigentlich also nicht nur
Netanyahu auch schon davor immer den
Siedlungsausbau vorangetrieben haben im
Westjordanland und das hat praktische
Auswirkung auf junge Menschen auf
Menschen in palästiner die eben sich
nicht frei bewegen können die nicht
einen Zugang zuur Bildung haben und zur
Arbeit wie die israelischen Bewohner
dort die kein kein Zugang zu
Dienstleistung haben zu Wasser die z.B
keine Wohnung bauen können die kein Haus
bauen könen ich ich möchte heiraten als
junger Mensch ich möchte neben dem Haus
meiner Eltern ein weiteres ich bekomme
keine Genehmigung dafür das ist diese
strukturelle dis wir dürfen das Wort
apaththeit nicht nicht benutzen weil
stellen sie stellen Sie sich mal vor was
ein Israeli da denken muss die Apartheit
die hat geendet ja und das hat dazu
geführt dass die Gegner die Gegner der
weißen in Südafrika die Macht übernommen
haben müssen wir müssen uns das immer
klar machen wir sagen den
Israel koloniale Herrschaft EUR
koloniale Herrschaft das sagt man mit
dem Begriff die geht damit die geht
vorbei und dann herrschen bei euch die
Araber und dann gehen natürlich alle
Alarmglocken an weil wir natürlich die
Israelis wissen was das bedeutet wir
alle wissen was das bedeutet deswegen
sollen auch nicht beschreiben als
aparit sind gerade bei einem schönen
Beispiel warum ich den Begriff aparit in
dem Zusammenhang nie verwende genau wir
müssenen alle über
den Realität in der westb stattfet ich
finde darüber soll
Manau über über ein ein ein Begriff
genau ich danke sehr viel gelernt heute
danke ihn allen ganz ganz herzlich